[موسيقى]
صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
في حديث خاص للعربيه رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا
يكشف عن تعيين رئيس لمكتب مكافحه الفساد
هذا الشهر
الوكاله الذريه تكشف عن يورانيوم مخصب
بنسبه تقل عن تسعين بالمئه الايرانيه
في تونس عمليات الاعتقالات تتوالى
الخارجيه تدعو لعدم التدخل في شؤونها
والمعارضه تطالب بتوضيح تهمه التامر على
الدوله
بعد ان احدث العالم الهولندي ضجه هزت
العالم بتوقعاته حول الزلازل من يستطيع
التنبؤ بالهزات وكيف الاجابه في اخبار
الساعه
[موسيقى]
اسعدوا اوقاتنا لم يكن في اخبار الساعه
اذا في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه تحدث رئيس
الوزراء الاوكرانيه عن ملفي محاربات
الفساد في بلاده المسؤول الاوكراني كشف
انه خلال الشهر المقبل سيتم تعيين رئيس
لمكتب مكافحه الفساد لمتابعه هذه القضايح
اربعه اجهزه حكوميه في اوكرانيا الشرطه
والمخابرات ومكتب مكافحه الفساد ومحكمه
مكافحه الفساد وخلال شهر مارس سيتم تعيين
رئيس مكتب مكافحه الفساد في اوكرانيا تكمل
الاجهزه المعنيه التحقيقات في ملفات عده
وانا مقتنع بانه حتى النصف الاول من شهر
مارس ستكون الحكومه وعينت رئيس المكتب
الوطني لمكافحه الفساد
قال كذلك في هذه المقابله ان بلاده نجحت
في تجنب ازمه للطاقه بدعم من حلفائها على
الرغم من الاستهداف الروسي المتكرر لمنشات
وشبكات الطاقه في اوكرانيا
تاثير الحرب على قطاع الطاقه في اوكرانيا
رئيسي احتل الروس محطه الطاقه النوويه
زابوريجي وهي الاكبر في القاره الاوروبيه
حيث تمتلك سته مفاعلات نوويه من القوه
الاولى وهذه المحطه تشكل ربع اي 25% من
قدره اوكرانيا على توليد الطاقه قبل الحرب
الابتزاز النووي لاوروبا والعالم ياتي عبر
احتلال هذه المنشاه النوويه اضافه الى
التهديد بالصواريخ النوويه فضلا عن ان
الضربات بالمسيرات على البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه دمرت نحو خمسه جيجا فولت من القدره
الاوكرانيه للطاقه اضافه الى ذلك تم تدمير
الشبكات الطاقه بالطبع فقدت اوكرانيا من
40 الى 50% من قدرتها على توليد الطاقه
لكن رغم ذلك بدعم من شركائنا تم تسليم
مولدات ومعدات جديده لذلك كنا قادرين على
اجتياز هذا الشتاء الصعب
مشاهدينا ايضا هذه هي المقابله الكامله مع
رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا اسمها اجرتها معه
الزميله ليالي الاختيار وتحدث في اشمها عن
دعم دول الخليج الانساني والاقتصاديه
لاوكرانيا كما تحدث عن العقوبات الجديده
التي تقترحها بلاده على روسيا تتابعون هذه
المقابله كامله غدا في الرابعه عصرا
بتوقيت السابعه مساء بتوقيت السعوديه
[موسيقى]
انتقد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه خطه الصين
للسلامه في اوكرانيا وقال انه لا يمكن لها
ان تدعم روسيا ثم تقدم مقترحا للسلام في
نفس الوقت
ين حينما نتحدث عن العدوان الروسي على
اوكرانيا لا يمكن ان تقدم مقترح سلام بيد
بينما تغذي شراره العدوان الذي بدات روسيا
باليد الاخرى لذا اتمنى ان تاخذ الصين ما
نقوله بجديه وما تقوله الدول الاخرى حول
العالم وان تبتعد عن اي دعم لروسيا
بعدم انضمام خمس من دول الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابق ومن بينها كازاخستان واوزباكستان
الى روسيا في الحرب ضد اوكرانيا وقال
بلينكن في مؤتمر صحفي في كازاخستان قبل
توجهه الى استانا ضمن جولته في اسيا
الوسطى انه شدد في جميع مناقشاته على
اهميه احترام سياده الدول واستقلالها
واشار الى ان دول اسيا الوسطى التزمت
بموقف محايد مدروس بشان اوكرانيا لا يدعم
العدوان الروسي كما قال
[موسيقى]
نتابع من الصحفي نادر رونج نادر اهلا بك
معنا في اخبار الساعه هل هناك رد من بكين
على كلام انطوني بلينكن بانها من جهه تدعم
روسيا بالاسلحه ومن جهه اخرى تقدم خطه
للسلام في اوكرانيا
اهلا ومرحبا
يعني هذه الالتحامات يعني
لن تقبلها ابدا لان هذه ليس لها يعني ادله
يعني على
تقديم الصين الاسلحه لروسيا والصين موقف
الصيني اتجاه الازمه يعني واضح مستمر منذ
بدايتها
تقدم اي اسلحه لاي طرف في النزاع والسين
دائما بجانب الحوار والسلام فلذلك هذه
الاتهامات ليس لها اساس من الصحه وكذلك من
هو من اجل التسويق سوره الصين فقط ولكن
نادر
يعني هل يعقل ان تتحدث الولايات المتحده
من فراغ كيف يمكن تفسير كذلك فعلا اذا ما
صح هذا الكلام يعني انه
هناك تقديم للاسلحه استعداد لتقديم اسلحه
وفي نفس الوقت تقدم خطه للسلام
رفضتها روسيا عمليا وقالت انه الوقت الان
ليس للتفاوض او لانهاء الازمه سلميه
طبعا يعني اولا لا
يعني ليس لديها استعداد للتقديم الاسلحه
لرؤيه لان
تعارض تقديم الاسلحه وفرض العقوبات على اي
طرف في هذا النزاع
وثم يعني
هناك الاستجابه يعني على الاقل هناك
استجابه الايجابيه من دال جانبي وروسيا
حسب علمي اعربت ان استعدادها لتفاوض
من اين جاءت هذه القصه قصه استعداد الصين
لتقديم اسلحه الى روسيا من اين جاء
الامريكيون بهذا الكلام
اعتقد يعني
هم يخافون الخوف فقط لان المخاوف
الامريكيه في هذه الايام دائما تحدث
ويعني عدم
[موسيقى]
الثقه بنفسه ودائما تعتبر الصين اكبر
تحديد لها
وكلها جاء من هذا القلق نعم طيب ولكن
عمليا الان نادر
الصين اين تقف بالضبط يعني هي لم تؤيد
صراحه العمليه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا هل سنشهد ربما في
المرحله المقبله موقفا واضحا من الصين
امام كل هذه الاتهامات الامريكيه
طبعا الصين يعني موقفها حيادي منذ البدايه
تدعوا دائما الى بدء التفاوض
وكذلك وقف اطلاق النار وترى ان الحوار
والتفاوض هو السبيل الوحيد الذي الازمه
وكذلك السيد ستبقى يعني حياديا وتبذل اكثر
جهودها مع المقتبى الدولي لاي شاري حاليا
سلمي من لهذه الازمه عبر التفاوت والحوار
نادي الرونج شكرا جزيلا لك من بكين
شكرا شكرا لكم
والاوضاع الميدانيه للمعارك في اوكرانيا
تشهد تصعيدا مستمرا في مختلف الجبهات
ابرزها ضخمه التي يتواصل فيها القتال منذ
اسابيع موسكو تواصل سعيها الحثيث للسيطره
على باخمت حيث تحاصرها من جهات متعدده ما
يشعل المعارك من حولها وهو ما اكده قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
الذي قال ان الوضع في محيط المدينه باخمت
اصبح متوترا للغايه الجنرال الاوكرانيه
اوضح ايضا ان القوات الروسيه دفعت بوحدات
هجوميه تابعه لمجموعه فاجنر في محاوله
لاختراق دفاعات الجيش الاوكراني بهدف فرض
حصار على المدينه وهذا ولم تتوقف الهجمات
الروسيه الاخيره عند حدود ضخمه بل امتدت
الى شرق خركيز ولمن ايضا نقلا عن الجيش
الاوكراني الذي اشار الى انه احبط الستين
هجوم الروسيا خلال 24 ساعه
ويبدو ان الصراع يسير نحو دخول فصل جديد
بعد اتهام موسكو الولايات المتحده بالقيام
باعمال استفزازيه باستخدام مواد كيماويه
بهذا الخصوص كشف قائد قوات الحمايه
الاشعاعيه والكيماويه والبيولوجيه في
الجيش الروسي ايغور كيريلود عن تقدم عربات
المدرعه امريكيه الصنع تحوي مواد كيماويه
نحو خط التماس استعدادا للقيام باعمال
استفزازيه بدورها قلت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان الولايات المتحده تخطط
لاستفزاز في اوكرانيا باستخدام مواد
كيماويه سامه
السعي الى الانضمام الى حلف الناتو لا
يزال مطلبا ملحا لفنلندا التي تبحث عن
طريق اخرى لتجاوز عقبه الرفض التركي
لملفها المشترك مع السويد في هذا السياق
فتح في لندن نقاشا في البرلمان في شان
مقترح انضمامها الى النيتو من دون انتظار
السويد على ان يتم التصويت وعلى هذا
المقترح في وقت لاحق وتريد حكومه رئيسه
الوزراء المنتهيه ولايتها سنه مارين تجنب
اي فراغ سياسي حتى تتمكن البلاد من دخول
النيتو سريعا ما ان تحصل على مصادقه تركيا
والمجر
[موسيقى]
وقع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين قانونا
يقضي بتعليق مشاركه روسيا في معاهده الحد
من الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه ستارت ووفقا
للقانون تم تعليق معاهده ستارت ويمكن
لرئيس الدوله اتخاذ قرار باستئناف مشاركه
روسيا في المعاهده ويدخل القانون حيز
التنفيذ في يوم نشره بالجريده الرسميه
[موسيقى]
الى ايران سجلت حالاته تسمم جديده لعشرات
التلميذات في محافظه طهران بعد سلسله
هجمات مماثله او حالات مماثله في قم
ومناطق ايرانيه اخرى نسبت الى افراد
يعارضون تعليم الفتيات وفق ما افادت وسيله
اعلام محليه وقالت وكاله تسنيم للانباء
بانه تم تسميم عدد معين من التلميذات في
مدرسه للبنات في مدينه بارديس الواقعه في
محافظه طهران واضافت بانه حتى الان تم نقل
35 تلميذه الى المستشفى مشيره الى ان
اجهزه الطوارئ موجوده في المدرسه للسيطره
على الوضع
[موسيقى]
اصدر السنه الجمهوريه وعضو لجنه العلاقات
الدوليه في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكيه بيانا
قال فيه ان رسو سفن الحربيه الايرانيه في
البرازيل يعد تطورا خطيرا وتهديدا مباشرا
لسلامه وامن الامريكيين كما اكد في البيان
على ان لدى الولايات المتحده قوانين
لمكافحه الارهاب مصممه لردع تهديدات والرد
عليها مشددا على ان السفن الحربيه
الايرانيه خاضعه للعقوبات وبالتالي فان
الميناء في الذي رصت فيه معرض الان
لخطر عقوبات شديده
[موسيقى]
كشفت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه عن
اكتشاف جزيئات يورانيوم مخصب في ايران تقل
نقاوتها عن 90% وهي نسبه كافيه لصنع سلاح
النووي وقال في الوكاله ان ايران ارجعت
هذه النسبه الى امكانيه حدوث خلل في عمليه
التخصيب الى ان الوكاله انتقدت ايران لعدم
الشفافيه في السماح بمراقبه منشاتها
النوويه وكانت الطاقه الذريه اكدت ان
مخزون ايران من اليورانيوم والمخصب بنسب
مختلفه زاد بنحو 87 كلغ منذ اخر تقرير
فصلي ليصل الى اكثر من
3760 كيلو جراما
افادت الوكاله ان هذا المخزون يتجاوز
السقف المسموح به لايران باكثر من ثماني
عشره مره كما اضافت الوكاله ان ايران
لديها 42 كلغ من اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه
60% وهو يحتاج لتعزيز بسيط لانتاج سلاح
نووي
نتابع من بروكسيل مع الصحفيه الايرانيه من
السيلاوي منى اهلا بك معنا هذا الكلام ليس
بجديد على موضوع اكتشاف يورانيوم او وجود
يورانيوم يقترب من نقاء 90% في ايران كيف
يتعامل الاوروبيون مع هذا التقرير الصادر
على الوكاله الدوليه يلتقى الذريه
تحياتي لك وللمشاهدين يعني انا اظن
الاوروبيين يتمنون انه هذه الخبرات تكون
صحيحه لانه في حال بالفعل تطلع الخبر صحيح
وايران وصلت لهذه المستويات لم يبقى امام
الدول الاوروبيه او حتى ولايه المتحده
الامريكيه انه يستخدموا الضربه العسكريه
ليوقفوا ايرانًا حدها وهم لا يتمنون ذلك
لذلك حتى الان يحاولون ان يتفاوضون مع
جمهوريه الاسلاميه ممكن ان يخرجوا هذا
اليورانيوم الى خارج ايران لانه لم يبقى
لايران غير يعني مرحله واحده لتصل الى
قنبله نوويه وحتى بمخططات اللي هم حصلوها
من
باكستان يعني من العالم من اول
باكستاني كان هناك مخططات لصناعه قنبله
نوويه وقتها ايرانيين قالوا انه لا لم
نعرف انها قنبله نوويه ولكن
نعم هذا ما اكتشفه المفتشون يعني ولكن هل
ربما ايران تخفي اكثر بمعنى بشكل مباشر هل
يمكن ان تكون ايران فعلا قد وصلت الى
القنبله النوويه
لا اظن ذلك لانه بالفعل سرقوا
الاسرائيليون كميات كبيره من المستندات
ووثائق ايرانيه
فبال بالفعل لديهم ممكن نقول تفاصيل دقيقه
عن برنامج النووي الايراني ان احنا نتكلم
عن نص طن من سيديهات ودي فيديوهات واوراق
خرجت بشواحن الى خارج ايران لذلك انا يعني
لدي هذا الاعتقاد انه لديهم بالتفاصيل ما
هي المواقع وما ايران لديها من امكانيات
ولكن ايضا التوقعات الاسرائيليه كانت تقول
من قبل شهرين انه ايران ليست بعيده لصناعه
القنبله النوويه يعني
صحيحه ويقعون امام
امام
الاوروبيون او الاطراف الاوروبيه كانت من
اكثر المدافعين على البقاء او الابقاء على
الاتفاق النووي مع ايران هل
بهذه النسب من التخصيب المكتشفه هل يتراجع
الاوروبيون بمعنى هل يتغير الموقف
الاوروبي هل الان وصلنا الى نقطه اللاعوده
في مساله تخفيض
انتاج اليورانيوم والالتزام بالاتفاق
النووي
يعني مع شخصيات اللي اراهم بالمفاوضه ما
يرام مثل جوزيف حاول يعني بشكل
يعني بشكل مقيوس يعني يحاول ان يصل على
الاتفاق مع ايران انا اقول ايران متى ماتت
الشخصيات مثل جوزيف كوريل اوف بعيدا
يتمنون الاتفاق معك يعني اذا يتغير هؤلاء
الشخصيات ممكن ولكن مع الاسف هؤلاء اللي
وصلوا البرنامج انه ايراني الى هذه
المرحله منى السيلاوي من بروكسل شكرا لك
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه الرئيس العراقي
يؤكد دعم عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد دعا بيان لوزاره
الخارجيه التونسيه البعثات الدبلوماسيه
المعتمده لديها الاحترام قوانين الدوله
وعدم التدخل في شؤونها الداخليه وشدد بيان
الخارجيه التونسيه على ضروره تقيد البعثات
الدبلوماسيه بمقتضيات اتفاقيه فيينا مشيره
الى ان تونس حريصه على تسهيل عمل واتصالات
البعثات الدبلوماسيه خدمه لعلاقات الصداقه
والتعاون مع البلدان الشقيقه والصديقه
ياتي ذلك اثر تتبع بعض الاشخاص متهمين
بالتامر على امن الدوله وذلك على خلفيه
اتصالاتهم مع بعثات دبلوماسيه معتمده في
تونس
هذا وتباينت الرؤوف الشريعه التونسي بخصوص
حمله الاعتقالات الجاريه والتي شملت اسماء
بارزه ومسؤولين بين مطالبه بالمحاسبه وداع
الى عدم استعمالها لتصفيه السياسيه مع
المحاسبه تكون محاسبه عادله اما على حسب
المعطيات اللي موجوده
اغلب معناها الملفات حسب اقوال محامين كل
شيء
ولذلك ماذا بنا احنا زاد كشعب وكل شيء
نحبو نعرفو الحقيقه
واش فيها الملفات هذه تهم الموجهه للاشخاص
اذا كان معناها
امورها واضحه معناها
غامضه احنا ماذا بينا كل شيخ ومجراه
القانون اللي يعمل لي خلص واحنا مع
الايقافات واذا كانوا ما فماش امورك تصفيه
حسابات هذه احنا نروح زايده ماذا بنا
تقولوا الامور في اطارها تطبيق القانون يا
سيدي
نوقفوهمه
حول قضيه الاعتداء على امن الدوله
الداخليه اسبوعا ثالث تتوسع دائره
المشمولين بالبحث فيها مع اصدار 10 بطاقات
ايداع بالسجن ضد عشره من المتهمين في
انتظار استكمال التحقيقات هددت المعارضه
بالنزول الى الشارع والاحتجاج في وقت عده
اوساط قانونيه ما يجري بدايه لتعافي
القضاء في مواجهه جرائم الفساد والارهاب
في البلاد
في مقر قطب مكافحه الارهاب لا تنتهي جلسه
استنطاق للمتهمين في قضيه التامر على امن
الدوله حتى تبدا اخرى وعمليات الايداع
بالسجن تتوالى لاول مره في قضيه بهذا
الحجم القضاء يستعيد عافيته هكذا يؤكد
المتابعون للملف
وقضى التحقيق في القطب الذين اصدروا
البطاقات هذوما في زمن
البحيري ما كانش بالامكان انه ربما حتى
الملف ما يتعداش النيابه بتاتا
من الدليل على ذلك ان هذه هناك جرائم او
ابحاث هناك ملفات الان على رفوف ما كانت
على رفوف معناها في وزاره العدل ولا في
الحكومه خرجت الى النور واصبح البحث فيها
عن عجائز من الناحيه الاجرائيه ومن
الناحيه القانونيه المعارضه على راسها
جبهه الخلاص بقياده النهضه تهدد بالنزول
الى الشارع بينما الرئيس قيس سعيد ماضن في
مشروعه لانقاذ البلاد كما يقول
القضيه تتفرع الى ملفات اخرى منها الارهاب
والفساد اليوم رئيس الجمهوريه يتقدم بخطاه
حديث
والشعاره في المحاسبه ايضا القضاء دخل على
الخط بقوه لكن يبقى ربما التحدي هو اناره
الراي العام وتقديم الروايه التي تدعم ما
يحدث اليوم في تونس مع دخول لقافاته في
قضيه التامر على امن الدوله الاسبوع
الثالث تلوح المعارضه بالنزول الى شارع
معتبره القضيه مفبركه بينما يؤكد مساندون
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه انها تمثل بدايه
التعافي الفعلي للقضاء في مواجهه ثالوث
الارهاب والفساد والتامر على امن الدوله
اما الشارع حاله يقول لا احد فوق القانون
مستقبلا ولابد من المحاسبه وكشف الحقيقه
للراي العام
في المحاسبه كانت حلم ينتظر التونسي الكل
والغرف المظلمه طلعت بالحق غرف مظلمه
واجتماعات بعد نص الليل وهذه اشياء يعني
ثابته جدا اكبر من الدوله ما ثم حتى حد
فوق القانون وتؤكد مصادر قانونيه ان دائره
الاتهامات والاحكام بالسجن ستشمل العشرات
مستقبلا مع تقدم التحقيقات في واحده من
اخطر القضايا منذ سقوط نظام الرئيس الاسبق
زين العابدين بن علي وليد عبد الله
العربيه تونس
ومن تونس ينضموا الينا خالد عبيد الباحث
في الشؤون السياسيه استاذ خالد اهلا بك
معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
سلسبيل شلالي وهي مديره منظمه
قالت بخصوص هذه الاعتقالات في تونس ان
الرساله من هذه الاعتقالات انا هنا اقتبس
حرفيا هي انك اذا تجرات على التحدث علانيه
يمكن للرئيس ان يعتقلك ويندد بك علنا
ويصفكم بالارهابيين دون جمع ادله موثوقه
ما ردكم على هذا الكلام
مساء الخير هو في الحقيقه هذا راي السيده
السيده هيوم الرايتس ووتش رايها وراي
يلزمها هي لكن في الواقع يجب ان نكون
واضحين انه الى حد الان بامكان ان تعبر عن
رايك هنا في تونس بامكانك ان تعارض حتى ما
يحدث بامكانك ان تقول بان هذه الايقافات
غير واضحه بان هذه الايقاف ايقافات يشوفه
يشوبها الكثير من الخلل في الاجراءات بان
هذه رقاصات ربما قد تكون رغبه من رئيس
الجمهوريه في
انهاء وجود المعارضه السياسيه التي تعارض
حكمها وتعارض اجراءاته ولذلك هذه المساله
بالذات يجب ان ننسبها كل شيء يجب تنسيبه
سواء من هذا الطرف او ذاك ولهذا السبب ان
تقول بانك بمجرد ان تعارض فانه يجب ان
تصمت او تسكت او يقع ايقافك هذه مبالغه في
رايي نعم ولكن في مطالعه للاسماء الموقوفه
من المعارضه التونسيه جميعها تذهب في هذا
الاتجاه انه منتقدوا ما يقوم به الرئيس
قيس سعيد وبعضهم وصفه بانه يسعى للتفرد
بالسلطه يعني هم رجال اعمال اعلاميين طبعا
جوهر بن مبارك القيادي في جبهه الخلاص رجل
الاعمال كمال اللطيف وزير الوزير السابق
الازهر العكرمي وكذلك
مدير موزاييك اف ام نور الدين بوطار كل
هذه الاسماء تعتقد انها يعني لها صلات
بجهات خارجيه وهي تتامر على الدوله
التونسيه
هذا الامر لا يمكن ان اثبتها او انفيه هذه
الامر هو يتعلق بالقضاء وعلى القضاء وخاصه
على النيابه العموميه التي تقوم
بالتحقيقات
بالتحقيقات ان تثبت ذلك نحن قلنا منذ
بدايه الايقافات والى حد الان على النيابه
العموميه او على السلطه التي تقف وراء هذه
الايقافات ان تخرج الى الراي العام
التونسي تبين حقيقه ما يحدث وتبين وفق ما
يسمح به بالنظر الى سريه التحقيقات تبين
ما هي الادله التي اعتمدت في مساله
الايقاف وذلك حتى يفهم الراي العام حقيقه
ما احدث لانه لدينا الان روايه واحده وهي
روايه متهمي محامي المتهمين وفي هذه
الروايه هناك تاكيد بان الملف مفبرك بان
الاوراق فارغه بانه ليس هناك اي تهمه
للتامر والمساله كلها رغبه من رئيس قيس
سعيد انهاء وجود السياسي لمعاريضيه لكن في
ذات الوقت هناك من مساند رئيس قيس سعيد من
يؤكد العكس ولهذا لا يمكن نحن ان نحسم
امرنا الا من خلال ان تخرج النيابه
العموميه في ندوه صحفيه وتبين تبين الادله
لانه
المنتقدون يقولون انه ليس هناك ادله واضحه
طيب هناك كذلك خارجيا حتى الاتحاد
الاوروبي اعرب عن قلقه من هذه
الاعتقالات الا ترى انه كذلك التوتر
العلاقه مع الاتحاد الاوروبي في هذه
المرحله سيعقد الامور اكثر على على تونس
هذا امر مرجح بالنظر الى ان تونس هي تعتمد
منذ استقلالي لحد الان على اساس ان
علاقاتها تكون جيده مع كل الاطراف باعتبار
ان الدبلوماسيه التونسيه تقوم على اساس
عدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه لايت دوله
وعلى اساس ان يكون هناك نوعا ما صفر مشاكل
ما دامت هذه الدوله او تلك لا تتدخل في
شؤون تونس الداخليه وهي تحرص تونس من قبل
والان وحتى غدا على ان تكون علاقاتها جيده
مع الدول الغربيه بالنظر الى شراكاتها
الاقتصاديه والماليه معها ولهذا السبب ما
يحدث الان وبالتاكيد سينقي بتلال على هذه
العلاقه بين الطرفين لكن وارجع مره اخرى
على الدوله في تونس ان توضح الامور كما
يجب لراي العام التونسي كما الاجنبي وقتها
ربما ستتبدد مثل هذه التوترات وتصبح
المساله مساله واضحه للجميع اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا
خالد عبيد كنت معنا مباشره من تونس
[موسيقى]
تسببت زلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا في احاله
الاف الاتراك الى البطاله بعد انهيار
المصانع والمحل التجاريه كما خلف ركودا
اقتصاديا كبيرا في الولايات الجنوبيه وسط
توقعات بتاثيرات سلبيه كبيره على نمو
الاقتصاد التركي خلال العام الجاري عبد
القادر خربوش
وسط كهرمان مرعش يحاول فاروق استرجاع ما
امكنه من سلع كان يعرضها في محله الذي
حوله الزلزال الى ركام
هذا الشارع كان تجاريا بامتياز وكنت امتلك
محلا لبيع السجاد من اربعه طوابق لكن
الزلزال قضى على كل شيء ولا اعلم كيف ومتى
ساعود لعمل مجددا
الكارثه التي اودت بحياه عشرات الالاف
خلفت كذلك ركودا اقتصاديا في الولايات
الجنوبيه للبلاد وحولت مواطنيها الناجين
الى حياه البطاله والعيش على المساعدات
حاليا اصبحت عاطلا عن العمل كما تشاهد
السوق وكل المحلات اصبحت ركاما حتى وان
اردت العوده الى تجاره فلن استطيع لاني لم
اعد املك شيئا
الزلزال ومثل ما دمر اليابسه وما عليها في
الجنوب التركي لحقت اضراره البحر كذلك
ومست الميناء حسب اقتصاد المنطقه ومصدر
قوت اهاليها ميناء اسكندرون بهاتاي لحقته
اضرار زلزال واوقفت نشاط صياديه
نفس الشكل كلهم كسر كله ما بنعرف كيف بدنا
نعمل شو بده يصير فينا تقرير للبنك الدولي
قدر اضرار الزلزال باربعه مليار دولار
فيما يرجح اقتصاديون تجاوز هذا الرقم
بكثير اما السلطات التركيه فدخلت في سباق
مع الزمن لاحتواء الازمه والتبعاتها عبد
القادر خربوش العربيه جنوب تركيا
[موسيقى]
وزلزال تركيا وسوريا حمل معه حركه عكسيه
للاجئين السوريين فالعديد منهم عاد الى
بلاده اما للاطمئنان على اقاربه او لقضاء
فتره نقاهه او بحثا عن ماوى بعدما دمر
الزلزال منزله في تركيا مسؤول في وزاره
الدفاع التركيه كشف ان نحو اربعين الف
سوري فرو من المناطق المتضرره في تركيا
وعادوا الى شمال غرب سوريا في الاسبوعين
الماضيين وما ساهم في هذه الحركه العكسيه
هو العرض الذي قدمته السلطات التركيه في
اعقاب الزلزال والذي يسمح للاجئين
السوريين في تركيا بقضاء ما يصل الى سته
اشهر في شمال غرب سوريا مع امكان عودتهم
الى تركيا مره اخرى
[موسيقى]
اكد المبعوث الامامي الى سوريا ان
الاستجابه فعاله لكارثه الزلزال تاثرت
بفعل النزاع لافتا ان الوضع الحالي اصبح
غير مقبول اطلاقا
[موسيقى]
والواقع الاليم هو ان الاستجابه الفعاله
قد تعرقلت بسبب التحديات المرتبطه
بالمسائل التي لا تزال عالقه وهي في صلب
النزاع لطالما كررت ان الحاله في سوريا
غير مستدامه وان الوضع الحالي غير مقبول
وان السوريين عرضه لمسائل لا يتحكمون بها
نفسهم
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس العراقي عبد اللطيف رشيد ان
بلاده تدعم عوده سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه جاء ذلك خلال لقائه مع وزير
الدوله البريطانيه لشؤون الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا طارق احمد واكد رشيد ان
بغداده تتمتع بعلاقات جيده وبناء مع دول
الجوار وفي سياق اخر اوضح الرئيس العراقي
ان هناك جهودا تبذل مع المنظمات الدوليه
لاعاده اعمار مدينه سنجار وانهاء ملف
نازحين وتطبيق اتفاقيه سنجار
[موسيقى]
زلزال تركيا وسوريا عاد الى الواجهه بشكل
كبير موضوع التنبؤات بالزلازل حيث باتت
اخباره توقعات الزلزال تلقى رواجا واسعا
على وسائل الاعلام ومنصات التواصل
الاجتماعي كما باتت اسماء العلماء
المتنبئين تتردد على نطاق واسع يتقدمهم
مؤخرا طبعا الهولندي فرانك هوجر بيتس الذي
تنبا بزلزال تركيا في السادس من فبراير
الماضي الدور جاء هذه المره
على الحديث هنا عن عالم الجيولوجيا
العراقي صالح محمد عوض الذي توقع وقوع
زلزال يوم الثامن من مارسا المقبل في
منطقه الصفيحه الاناضليه وهو التنبؤ الذي
يضاف الى تحذيرات الهولندي هوجربيت الذي
حذر من زلزال جديد في الاسبوع الاول من
شهر مارسا المقبل
الى ماذا يستند العالمان العراقي
والهولندي في تنبؤاتهما بالنسبه للعالم
العراقي فان زلزال المتوقع حدوثه يوم
الثامن من مرسى المقبل على حد قوله سيكون
اقل ضررا من زلزال تركيا وسوريا موضحا ان
هناك انتشارا للزلازل على الصفيحه
الاناضليه الشرقيه وبان وضع القمر يوم
الثامن من مرسى المقبل سيكون نفس وضعه في
السادس من فبراير يوم حدث زلزال تركيا
وسوريا المدمر
اما هوجر بيتس الذي تنبا بزلزال تركيا
المدمر فقد ظهر بالفيديو يشرح نظريته حيث
ربط بين الانشطه الزلزاليه المتوقعه
واكتمال القمر وشدد على ان اول اسبوع من
شهر مارس سيكون حرجا مشيرا الى ان بعض
الانشطه الزلزاليه قد تتخطى ثماني درجات
على مقياس ريختر
[موسيقى]
العالم الهولندي فرانكو سرق الانظاره اذا
بعدما توقع حدوث زلزال تركيا توقعه جعل
اسمه ينتشر على نطاق واسع وجعل قراءاته
وتنبؤاته محطه اهتمام الكثيرين لكن ما مدى
مصداقيه ودقه تنبؤات العالم الهولندي شكوك
عديده اثيرت حول كفاءتي واهليه الرجل وهو
ما تحدث عنه الدكتور عباس شراقي استاذ
الجيولوجيا بجامعه القاهره والذي اكد ان
الهولنديه المتنبه بالزلزال ليس بعالم او
جيولوجي ولا يحمل درجه علميه واحده بل هو
مجرد يوتيوبر استغل حدوث الزلزال لتحقيق
الشهره وقال الدكتور عباس الشراقي ان
المتنبي الهولندي لا يستند في تنبؤاته على
اسس علميه ترتبط بالجيولوجيا والقشره
الارضيه وحركتها بل يعتمد على حركه النجوم
عن طريق برنامج كمبيوتر وكشف الخبير
المصري ان المتنبي الهولندي يختار المناطق
الاكثر تعرضا للزلزال ليقدم تنبؤاته حولها
على امل ان تصيب احدا ها
معنى من بيروت الاستاذ في علم الجيولوجيا
سمير زعاطيطي استاذ سمير اهلا بك معنا في
اخبار الساعه طيب
صدقت تنبؤات العالم الهولندي صدفه مره طيب
لكن مرتين هل هي في كل مره صدفه
سيدي الكريم تركيا وفيها خطين زلزليين
ناشطين معروفين
الصفيحه العربيه التي تصطدم مع الصفيحه
الاوراسيه ومن ناحيه اخرى عندك المتوسط
الذي ينزلق تحت تركيا هذه الخطوط حتما
حتما نشط زلزاليا نشطه وهناك زلازل قبل
الزلزال التركي كنا نعرف هناك زلازل
ودائمه في بحر ايجا وفي البحر وفي على
الخط وما قاله الزميل المصري تماما هؤلاء
ليسوا بعلماء جيولوجيين هؤلاء علماء فلك
عندما يربط الزلازل مصدرها باطني مئه
بالمئه باطني داخلي حيث لا نستطيع الولوج
لا نستطيع الدخول ومعرفه
التفاعلات النوويه التي تحصل الطاقه
الحراريه الكبيره
هنا السؤال يعني لانه الناس صارت محتاره
بالنظر الى انتم تقولون انها صدفه يعني
توقعه صدقه مرتين ولكن هل يمكن في العلم
هل يمكن ان يكون هناك تاثير لحركه القمر
او لجاذبيه القمر او لجاذبيه كواكب اخرى
بمعنى هل يمكن حركه الكواكب وجاذبيتها على
كوكب الارض يمكن ان يكون لها دور في
الزلازل ام هذا يعني قولا واحدا كلام غير
علمي وغير صحيح
اخي القمر
له قوه جاذبيه هو لا يستطيع تحريك صخور هو
يستطيع تحريك المياه يشدها نعم
فتنحسر المياه عن حركه المد والجزر عندما
يمر هذا القمر ترجع هذه المياه حركه
الماده والجزر اكثر من هذا لا يوجد
واصطفاف الكواكب الكواكب المجموعه الشمسيه
اذا الشمس
الهولندي تكلم عن شمس هي التي تحرك
الصفائح الشمس هذا النجم الضخم الكبير
لحجمه مليون مره حجم الكره الارضيه نعم لو
استطاع ان يؤثر يؤثر على الطبقه الغازيه
او على الطبقه المائيه لانها اخف وزنا
فكيف بك بصفائح سميكه
طيب دكتور سمير ولكن الناس تريد ان تعرف
ما التفسير يعني ما تفسير غير معقول ما
التفسير لهذا العالم الهولندي انه مرتين
صادف انه توقعاته حدثت بحدوث الزلزال صحيح
انه يعني كما ذكرت المنطقه في تركيا تلاقي
لصفيحتين
لكن ما التفسير ان تصدق توقعاته مرتين
طيب انا تصدق اللي هو لم يصدق هناك خطين
زلزاليان عليهم نشاط زلزالي موجود منذ
تكون الارض ليته يقول لنا متى سيحدث وما
هي قوته
واين بالضبط الان هو يتوقع في الاسبوع
الاول من شهر مارس دكتور سمير انا اقول
والناس باتت خائفه كثيرا انه هو قانون
الاسبوع الاول من شهر مارس سيحدث زلزال
وهناك الان كما ذكرنا عالم جيولوجيا عراقي
يتوقع يوم الثامن من مارس
رسالتك للمشاهدين هل علينا ان ناخذ حذرنا
في هذا اليوم او في هذه الفتره ام لا هذا
محض يعني افتراء او ادعاء
هؤلاء علماء فلك وليسوا بعلماء جيولوجيا
الزلازل والبراكين مصدر طاقتها الاساسيه
هي باطنيه داخليه وليس لها علاقه ولا باي
شكل لا بشمس ولا بكواكب ولا بقمر الطاقه
الدورانيه للكره الارضيه هناك ولا بقمر
القمر بس
هذا علم وهذا كل الموسوعات وكل المختبرات
وكل الابحاث العلميه وكل الجامعات التي
تحترم نفسها كتبت هذا وانا كنت اعلم هذه
المواد اول سنه جامعه طيب نعم انت مختص
اذا دكتور سمير في هذا المجال رسالتك
للمشاهدين الان عبر شاشه العربيه للذين
سمعوا هذه التنبؤات بالزلازل ماذا تقول
الان للمشاهدين دكتور سمير
اقول للمشاهدين اطمئنوا هذا ليس بكلام
علمي العلم لا يستطيع التنبؤ
بمصدر الطاقه الداخلي الباطن الموجود في
الارض نحن لا نستطيع التنبؤ بالزلازل ولكن
هناك خطوط زلزاليه معروفه يجب ان نعمل مثل
مثل اليابان لبن ماذا عملت ابحاث علميه
وعملت ابنيه مضاده وكل مواطن يعرف
بحال وصول زلزال ماذا يفعل المراه في
بيتها الرجل في الشارع في السياره في
المصعد على الدرج كل شخص يعرف ماذا يجب ان
يفعل
لا يجب ان نقول التنبؤ لان لان هذا الخط
هو زلزالي بالاساس هو في نشاط زلزالي
وبركاني يعني ممكن يحصل فيه زلزال في اي
لحظه في اي وقت واعتقد
نعم ولكن اعتقد ان هذا الخط الزلزالي قد
ارتاح قداح هناك طاقه محبوسه وطاقه كبيره
كانت
7.8 على مقياس ريختر هو هو رقم قياسي
بالنسبه للتركيه وبالنسبه للشمال السوري
شفنا الاضرار وشفنا كذا وبعدين اللي هي
اخف اخف وطئه اخف شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور سمير زعاطيطي كنت معنا
مباشره من بيروت
[موسيقى]
فاصل نواصل بعده واخبار الساعه ابقوا معنا
مرحبا بكم من جديد حكمت محكمه الجزائيه في
الدنمارك على امراه تحمل الجنسيتين
الدنماركيه كانت قد اجليت من معسكر اعتقال
في سوريا في 2021 حكمت عليها بالسجن اربعه
اعوام وجردتها من جنسيتها الدنماركيه
بتهمه مساعده مصلح تنظيم داعش
اعلن البرلمان الاوروبي انه قرر حظر
استخدام الموظفين لتطبيق تيك توك الصيني
لاسباب امنيه افدى مسؤول في البرلمان
الاوروبي بان القرار سيشمل كافه الاجهزه
والوسائل المثبته عليها تطبيق تيك توك
واوضح المسؤول ان القرار ياتي بسبب مخاوف
من استغلال بيانات الموظفين لصالح الصين
الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز اخبارها
في حديث خاص للعربيه رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا
يكشف عن تعيين رئيس لمكتب لمكافحه الفساد
هذا الشهر
الوكاله الذريه تكشف عن يورانيوم مخصب
بنسبه تقل عن 90 بالمئه تم اكتشافه في
منشاه فوردو الايرانيه
في تونس عمليات الاعتقال تتوالى الخارجيه
تدعو لعدم التدخل في شؤونها والمعارضات
تطالب بتوضيح تهمه التامر على الدوله
بعد ان احدث العلم الهولندي ضجه هزت
العالم بتوقعاته حول الزلازل من يستطيع
التنبؤ بالهزات وكيف تعرفنا على الاجابه
خلال اخبار الساعه
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]